what is the point in bringing a vote of
no confidence when you know the tories
are not going to vote for it
well we think boris johnson should go
now um and we hope that our the
conservative mps agree with us um on
that you know a lot of them resigned on
mass recently a lot of them have voted
against boris johnson i think the whole
country uh realizes that boris johnson
just has no integrity and honesty i
think it's time for him to go yeah but
they want to they don't want a general
election they want a new prime minister
the vote of no confidence can lead to
the prime minister resigning and if
another conservative mp commands the
confidence of a majority of parliament
then they can take over as an interim
leader until the new leader is appointed
in september but i just don't think
anyone feels comfortable with leaving
boris johnson in position as prime
minister particularly over summer you
know parliament doesn't sit over summer
it's very hard to keep scrutiny on what
he's doing i think don't you worry we'll
keep an eye on him that's good that's
good to hear you know but we'd like to
do that as well
in parliament and we want to make sure
and that he goes as quickly as possible
i think that is the overwhelming feeling
amongst people in the country and i
think the conservatives should take this
opportunity uh to get him out now so why
do you want this vote of no confidence
well we had hoped that the conservative
party in parliament their 1922 committee
would have done the right thing when
they met i think it was last night and
got porridge johnson out of office and
put in place a caretaker leader until
the new person is appointed in september
they didn't do that
and so we now feel forced to table this
vote of no confidence um as the last
opportunity uh to get boris johnson out
of downing street uh before the end of
parliament next week so just to clarify
it's not that you're trying to
push for a general election is because
you're trying to get the prime minister
out of downing street well we want a
general election you know we would love
a general election you know we want uh
that to happen as soon as possible but
this is also an opportunity uh primarily
to get rid of boris johnson and so
conservative mps if they really mean it
that they think boris johnson is not fit
to hold office and they want him out
this is an opportunity for them to get
him out this week they're a bit busy
voting on an election campaign
themselves
well they are busy at that but the
country needs to be run properly um and
i think having someone in 10 downing
street for the next few months who has
totally lost the trust of the people two
months it's until the 5th of september
so it's six weeks or so yeah but it's an
important time there's a huge amount
going on we don't want the government to
be in paralysis over the summer we don't
want the government to be headed up by
someone who's totally lost their
confidence but you guys said that it was
in paralysis for the last few months
well it has been i have it always we
need to get on and deal with the cost of
living crisis we need to make sure that
the government is actually taking a lead
on the issues the country is facing um
and the truth is the prime minister does
not have that confidence of the people
across the country and i think the
conservative mp should do the right
thing and get him out of office uh you
criticize tory leadership candidates
plans for so-called unfunded tax cuts um
in what way are they unfunded and what
are your
wealth tax plans well
there's been a
bonanza of fantasy economics over the
last few days you know conservative
leadership hopefuls have been falling
over themselves to promise tax cuts and
if you top them all up you know there's
some kind of 330 billion pounds worth of
unfunded spending commitments
which you see not chasm well richie
sunak has his own credibility problems
you know he's been talking about wanting
to cut taxes but people only have to
look at his immediate record as
chancellor of the last few months which
is that he raised
taxes on working people through
increasing national insurance right in
the middle of a cost of living crisis
making us the only g7 economy to raise
taxes on working people in this cost of
living crisis um the windfall tax which
we've been saying should be going toward
helping with the cost of living he was
delaying supporting that for months and
months he's had the wrong calls and all
the big issues that we've been facing
and so i don't think he has any
credibility either um i spoke to nadim
zahawi at length also my colleague beth
robie has spoken to satya javid and both
of them are saying that they would cut
the fat from government departments and
that would be enough to fund these tax
cuts that they're talking about
well i mean it's hard to keep track of
all of their unfunded spending
commitments there are 330 billion pounds
worth of them you know i saw some clips
of what nadine sahar we told you on your
show um yesterday and he seemed to be
talking about you know 20 cuts across
the board you know but he has to lay out
real plans for this you know does he
mean 20 cuts to the nhs you know how
many doctors and nurses is mean that
does he mean 20 does he mean 20 cuts to
defense does he mean 20 percent cut to
schools what does he mean by it
is within the operating daily operating
of the department who's watching this
this is just fantasy economics you know
these are not credible he said he did it
at the department of education and it
worked he needs to lay out his plans if
he wants to be prime minister of how
he's going to implement what he's saying
he's going to do and the truth is this
is all make-believe this is all fantasy
this is all
a desperate attempt by no deems of
harvey and all the other conservative
candidates to distance themselves from
boris johnson and to try and distance
themselves from the 15 tory tax rises
which they've supported over the last
few years
he's the chancellor
at the moment he says he's got a grip of
what's happening as far as the finances
of the country are concerned he's an
incredibly wealthy man and there are
several multi-millionaires in this
contest they show that they can run
business well so ergo they can run the
government well the country well
well i think the bigger question is
being asked of many of them at the
moment is about their own tax affairs um
and actually if you're going to have
someone in charge of the country's tax
system and you want to believe that
they're going to preside over a fair tax
system the idea that there are serious
questions being raised about their own
personal or family finances really
damages trust in that do you not believe
sir howie well let's see if he and the
other candidates are all going to come
clean and be really straightforward
about their tax affairs do you not think
he was during my interview well i think
some of the questions were like some of
the answers were quite carefully worded
and i think there were questions being
raised now
well i could go back through the tape
and have a look but like which ones were
you particularly uncomfortable with
because i tried to be as thorough as
possible when i was talking to you you
definitely pushed him on all those
questions but there are other questions
which we could ask of him and today
we've got sanjay javid well today we've
got sanji jabbar for instance you know
he was saying he wanted to
publish his tax returns and so on if he
was in the final two but then when
pushed on further details of where i
think where his offshore trust was or
something he wasn't able to answer it
there's a whole lot of there's a whole
lot that was cool there's a whole
there's a whole there's a whole myriad
of questions that need to be answered
and i think the point is uh that people
have so many questions
you're marking my homework from
yesterday so tell me what else i need to
have asked him sorry i'm not trying to
like
actually
no i definitely definitely i wouldn't i
wouldn't i would i wouldn't dare do that
you know i i think there's a job for us
to do in parliament as well and as mps
and to push them to come clean about all
of their tax affairs because trust has
been damaged you know fundamentally in
politics and we need to make sure we
push conservative leadership hopefuls to
come clean about what their position is
i understand that but what is it what
else is it that you need to know from
these people we know that because we
heard from rachel mclean that sadie
javid uh was registered offshore in
singapore that was that was what she was
trying you didn't tell us yesterday i'll
give you that but she said it was
singapore this morning so unless he says
different that's what we're going with
singapore
and as far as
zawi is concerned um he said that he is
going if he's in the final two he's
going to tell tell us um about his tax
returns in future now the question to
that would be warbler in the past i did
ask him that but do you think it's
important to know about what happened in
the past
i think it's an important question to
ask and i think we should know where
people stand who want to be in charge of
the country's taxation system uh you
know my colleague annelisa dods has
written to the conservative party about
the importance of coming clean about all
of the tax affairs of the different
conservative leadership hopefuls and i
think this comes to a question of trust
in politics you know i think trust has
been really damaged we know it's been
severely damaged by what boris johnson
has done in recent years and if we've
got people who are standing to be in
charge of the country and they need to
try and rebuild that honesty and
integrity and i don't think i've seen
any evidence from the conservative
leadership candidates that they're going
to be able to do that
do you acknowledge before i let you go
that all of the people that taking part
in the contest are honest people
i i think to be honest they have been
propping up boris johnson for the last
few years and they have become totally
entangled
in the problem that he's created with
politics and i think when i look at them
i think you know what changing at the
top of the conservative party is not
going to be any change at all